Natasha I was really excited about you
being here because you've been on the
show a bunch of times and every time I
talk to you I'm deliriously happy
because you are you are a singularity
you are unlike anybody else that I speak
to you are such an original uh speaker
of speaking and speeches and speech of f
but you are not no no I I was I was
Obama's speech
writer that's why most of his speeches
about the affordable act started out
like now listen to me yeah now listen up
country emphasis on the C I said
it I thought you were wrote his best
speeches thank you you know a lot of I
don't get a lot of credit for that and
so I really appreciate you bringing it
up a lot of people just think of me as
like uh I don't know whatever my captain
Bruno Kirby or some and I'm like
honey like I wrote Obama's most
iconic Fe you did you are such a great
uh Speech writer for Obama but also um
you you fell through a black hole you
come from another time um you are what
would you call yourself a
ragamuffin yeah well I do appreciate
that instead of saying singular you
actually called me the singularity
so our first test subject and uh you
know what's Wild is people thought that
Ray kurtwell was a c
you know what I mean they thought he was
some sort of a wackadoodle um I think
it's because you know he he did talk
about the singularity and uh early but
then uh the back half of the documentary
really ends with discovering that the
reason he wants this sort of um life
extension Singularity is so he can
resurrect his uh dead father and bring
him back from the dead which kind of
undid I think uh his theories cuz it
seemed like you know he was just some
sort of a character out of Young
Frankenstein but um yes that's actually
uh how I think of myself as as the final
merging of technology and uh
Humanity that was some run yeah it was
good that was an incredible speech you
just gave better than anything you wrote
for Obama yeah thanks that was well
because I like to take people on a loop
the where is this going and then I slide
into no plate you know what I mean into
just no play that wasn't just yeah that
wasn't just a roller coaster that was a
Coney Island roller coaster made of wood
it has a little bit of GI to have you
been on that roller coaster oh yeah
I've swam in that one I don't give a
was in it you know I was on that
roller coaster once and it gives oh you
feel it give on the corners it's made of
like Old Pine and that's a roller
coaster is not something I want to be
vintage I also don't want my eye
operation to be vintage did you get
lasic no I didn't but I'm just saying if
I were to have my eye operated on I
wouldn't want to go all retro and cool
you know like give me the uh give me the
instruments from 1885 just cuz I want to
be all steampunk yeah that's not me I
want that I don't want that well I won't
do it then look look honestly this one
you can just do it I I I'm being too
uptight and I can tell and you look you
look bummed down I want you no that's
just my face it is yeah I'm kind of just
that's my my neutral face is slightly
depressed oh really and when people see
me on the street they often ask me hey
Conan what's matter cuz when they they
know me from the days of jumping around
like a mad you just no I'm just is it
also your neutral State partly depressed
I I don't think that's true I think I'm
slightly anxious maybe and maybe I am
thinking a lot about how briefly uh I am
on this planet and how soon I'll be
moldering in my tomb those things come
to mind a lot yeah not afraid ctz has
his way with you this is
going to bring you right back the name
of this documentary uh transcendental
man maybe but I'm just uh pulling from
The Ether uh I think it is maybe Google
it yeah okay he we got Eduardo on it
right now or that or he's buying
something on Amazon it's one of the
others he buying another messy Jersey
transcended man yeah transcend
Transcendent man well uh close enough
but listen so you're basically just uh
you know a baby genius and uh that's not
your problem right so are you depressed
are you existential or you just like
thinking thoughts I'm just thinking
thoughts sounds to me like you might be
thoughts yeah and thoughts Drive
emotions ask any yeah they do and
feelings aren't facts exactly and now
we've done our service now we're okay
goodbye
everybody been the shortest this is the
shortest podcast we've ever
done